هل يمكنك أن تعطيني رد فعلك على
هذا التقرير الذي يتم نشره الآن على الملأ ،
شكرًا لك على استضافتي ، أريد فقط
أن
أشارك مشاعري كريستيانا ،
أنا محطمة أكثر من أي وقت مضى
الآن ، وأعتقد أنه لن يعود أبدًا ،
لقد نظرت للتو إلى صور جمال  أنني
التقطت
واحدة تلو الأخرى ،
لا أعرف ماذا أريد أن أقول ،
لكني أود أن قلت ذلك وقمت
بالتغريد لك على تويتر العدالة لجمال في إحدى
تلك الصور الجميلة
التي وضعتها ،
نعم ، التقطتها في المنزل بأكمله.
أخذتها بنعم
وأجمل صورة غدًا ،
لذا أود أن أرى قادة العالم
أه
لاتخاذ إجراء من أجل العدالة لجمال
يمكنني القول أنه الآن فقط
حسن المظهر ، نحن نقدر أن تأتيك ،
إنها لحظة عاطفية بشكل لا يصدق
بالنسبة لك  وكان عليك أن تتعايش
مع هذا أه طوال هذه السنوات
ولكنك تعرف نشاطك بالنسبة له
يسمعه الجميع في العالم والآن
هذه خطوة أخرى نحو
إثبات ما حدث له معلمتها
تشانغيس شكرًا جزيلاً لك.  ح لكونك
معنا
هذا المساء